hey guys it's max max tech after over
two weeks of waiting and having this
fancy stand in our office we finally got
the pro display XDR this is Apple 6k
display and in this video we not only
are going to check it out and give you
guys our impressions but we're also
going to be testing out a bunch of
different computers with this display to
see what works and what doesn't
I've got to say this packaging is
insanely heavy and thick the display is
very well protected let's pull out this
display and this is basically like a
slate and it's extremely extremely heavy
I've never held up a display that's this
dense here as you guys can see Pro
display XDR and on the back jeez Louise
this is it's crazy we're gonna bring it
close here and bam that's why I pay
$1000 deficit and that does that now I'm
just I'm completely kidding so inside
the box we do have all of our cables and
some accessories just like the Mac Pros
power cable the Thun are both three
cable and the power cable they are both
really high-quality and braided so I
don't have the Nano texture one I have
the 5k LG display which by the way I
will be doing a direct comparison again
so make sure you guys are subscribed if
you want to see that I don't have any
issues with the 5k display as far as
reflections so I did not spend the extra
money for that there okay not bad let's
go up I want to stop there stop there
all the way up let's tilt back and
unlock it there you go and I just heard
it locked so when you go into vertical
you can't go up or down it actually
locks in to make sure that you don't you
know hit the stand here let's flip that
switch again
and now we're back to adjusting not bad
now before we go and attach all these
computers and see what works what works
halfway and what doesn't work at all let
me give a big shout-out to Micra Center
for sponsoring our Mac Pro and Pro
Display XD our content my croissant has
25 stores nationwide with an impressive
variety of electronics from gaming VR
computer parts like processors graphics
and everything else needed to build or
upgrade a PC or Mac Micra Center has
been an authorized apple dealer since
1980 they have a dedicated Apple
Department with highly trained Apple
sales associates aside from the iPhone
micro carries the full lineup of Apple
products and they have the largest
selection of third-party products made
for Mac and iPad come into a local Micro
Center today and talk to one of the
Apple experts to order the specific Mac
Pro configuration that best suits your
needs check the link in the description
to find a local micro center near you or
browse all of micro centers Apple
products all right guys let's get into
the testing yes I'm wearing something
different because I'm reshooting the
second portion because things got a
little bit interesting and I decided to
add an even more system so let's start
out with the new 11th iPad pro and yes
even though we do not have Thunderbolt 3
of the system it is mirroring the iPad
if I go ahead and open up a YouTube
video we still do not get full screen
playback and we are not getting HDR
either even though of the display
supports it plugging in my 2018 15 inch
MacBook Pro it does work but everything
is incredibly tiny here by default which
is weird for Apple and I am not getting
any profile options any HDR anything
like that and in fact it's actually
running at 4k resolution not even 5k and
that's because I have Mac OS muhabba
running on here not catallena now if you
have a 2018 or 2019 MacBook Pro with
Catalina right away you not only will
see the UI being larger but it works
like it's supposed to at 6k resolution
and we
as far as our presets the 1600 net
preset which is the max as this monitor
could do so we're running in 10 bit HDR
and we have all of our profile options
so if you're going to be editing photos
you want srgb you want DCP three you
want it to force it into always-on HDR
you have all of those options and this
is the way the system was intended to
work all right guys now it's the time to
test out this 15-inch MacBook Pro which
has a horrible built-in display and not
only does the system not have
Thunderbolt 3 or USB type-c ask
Thunderbolt 2 so I'm using a Thunderbolt
3 to thinner bow to adapter the Apple
cells and let's go ahead and plug the
system in and you might be as shocked as
I was to see that yes it does work it is
running a 5k instead of 6 K but not only
is it running and working over
Thunderbolt 2 it is actually running
with the profiles enabled and I don't
have Catalina Version 15.2 installed
it's just 15 on here and that's not
supposed to like support the profiles
but the profiles are showing up I am
very surprised I'm not sure if it's
running in 10 bit or not but seeing as
we're having the 1600 nits HDR XDR
support it makes it seem like it is and
if that is true that is a shocker
because there's so much systems out
there that have integrated graphics
there Intel graphics width under Bowl 2
and if you can make this work with 10
bit HDR editing content that's crazy
because with a lot of other systems
windows systems you have to have a high
end say Quattro graphics card but this
has an intel graphics card but it does
work and I was really really surprised
if you have a 2019 iMac with under both
three it will run this display in full
6k with 10 bit HDR everything's gonna
run perfectly fine it's gonna work great
but if you have a 2017 or older iMac it
will actually only run in 5k resolution
even if you're connecting to an iMac Pro
because the Thunderbolt 3 controllers
DisplayPort is actually an older design
you still get all the other benefits of
the color accuracy the HDR the profiles
you are limited to 5k now before we test
out some Windows machines including an
Asus system with a Quattro graphics card
let me test out the Google pixel book go
this is a Chromebook that I absolutely
love as a I 5 CPU with Intel integrated
graphics and a USB type-c port and when
I plug it in it's very interesting that
the pro XDR display actually shows up at
the bottom of Chrome OS and it actually
shows that it is seeing the system it's
mirroring the system and I can actually
switch to extend displace as well the
display actually never powers on even
though Chrome OS thinks it does so who
knows maybe in the future if it's a
small setting or a driver
it could be updated to get it to work
with this crazy display that costs 12
times as much as this Chromebook and now
what a lot of you guys are waiting for
we have a Windows laptop here this is
the Dell XPS 2 and one with 10
generation Intel CPUs and graphics with
the full speed Thunderbolt 3 ports and
even though in the system it actually
shows up as a 5k display it sees the
name and allows me to change some
settings no matter what I do is not
working and I actually actually went in
and I updated the drivers to the latest
drivers it's a no-go so let's test out a
Windows system that has a much more
capable and video Quadro graphics card
so here we have an asus mini pc it has a
9900 K in a quadrille P 4000 graphics
card and I was surprised that yes it did
connect and it is running and it's
actually running at 5 K resolution not 6
K and another surprising thing was that
I actually was able to enable HDR
playback which then showed up as 10 bit
the brightness did kind of get knocked
down with HDR but when we're playing
back a video it does seem that we're
getting some good brightness now one
issue I came across like the other
window systems is I cannot adjust the
brightness of the display even with the
HDR turned off and when I'm playing back
in YouTube we're only getting 4k HDR
playback the a.k option is missing the
same thing goes for Microsoft edge
browser but HDR works for both now other
than some
Internet issues that I'm having here I
am not actually getting good flavorings
per second stuttery running at about
maybe 12 to 15 and that is because it is
actually not using the Quadro graphics
card in here it is just using integrated
graphics so that is kind of weird I went
through all the settings I could not
adjust it so yes this monitor does half
way kind of work with a system like this
let's try out another a laptop here this
is the Microsoft little surface laptop 3
this also has 10 generation Intel CPU
and graphics but one thing it does not
have is Thunderbolt 3 this is USB type-c
only and I was shocked to see that yes
not only does it identify it it
automatically shows up and it is running
and not only is it running it is running
in 6 K even though it doesn't have
Thunderbolt 3 and this is a thunder both
rhe monitor as Apple's marketing it just
like my LG 5k but my LG 5k cannot use
USB type-c to connect it needs
Thunderbolt 3 this is working whereas
the Dell XPS with a similar graphics
card but Thunderbolt 3 is not now it is
running an 8 bit non 10 bit I am NOT
getting HDR option and it is easier to
run a 6k resolution 8 bit which is 16
million colors compared to running out
5k with HDR 10 bit which is actually 1
billion different shades of different
colors so it can't run in that option
but still I am really surprised that it
works and now this has got me thinking I
have to try a 16 inch MacBook Pro
running Windows in boot camp and to see
what happens and it is running in 6k 10
bit as well and it gives me the option
to turn on HD are you know one option we
don't get just like with the other
Windows systems is the ability to change
the brightness and one really cool thing
to see is that we actually have the
option to play back HDR video if we look
at the video on the macro pro screen we
can see the whole sky is blown out just
like if you're recording a standard
video with a DSLR you can't get that
full dynamic range in the shot
but if I just drag this window BAM we
not only have the shadow details there
with the sky is perfectly maintained
just like you're looking at it with your
eyes and I don't know how it comes
through on our video because our video
is not an HDR right now but with the Mac
Pro endless display
we're hoping to start outputting HDR
videos and this is why this display is
really exciting for us personally we're
able to see something that's much more
realistic in terms of dynamic range then
you can before so thank you guys for
watching let me know if you have any
questions down below in the comment
section I will be taking a look at those
and maybe incorporating some of your
guys's
thoughts and questions into our review
of the Apple Pro display XDR I'd love to
hear you guys's opinions once again
thank you to micro center you guys can
find those links down in the video
description this man max with max tech
you guys can click that circle above to
subscribe and watch one of our other
great videos maybe on Mac Pro right over
there and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]